i've been hearing about this tribe of  people called the hadza they were this  fascinating group of people for me they  were just this tribe that were some of  the last remaining hunter-gatherers left  on the planet these are people who don't  farm they just hunt every day and they  gather food they don't even have  dwellings that are permanent they have  thatched huts they make and they break  them down they have camps they move  around this area in africa called lake  eyasi  and they just let you be a part of the  tribe and we got to hunt with them we  got to hang out with them we sat by the  campfire  at six in the morning and 7 30 at night  we got to sing with them and just eat  with them i mean i ate  crazy stuff with them like like baboon  brains  would you do it  i mean i'd probably try about anything  it would be it would be a mind over  matter thing it actually was really good  i've had brains i've had brains before  so i didn't think it was going to be bad